welcome back to 820 special relativity
in this section we want to discuss the
classical doppler effect
the doppler effect was first noted by
christian doppler hence the name
in 1842
and what we're discussing as a doppler
effect is a frequency change when moving
from one reference frame into another
so this can happen for example if the
source of a sound wave is moving like we
experience when a car is passing by
application of the doppler effect are
numerous
we can use the doppler effect to measure
the velocity of the speeding car
we can use the doppler effect to measure
the distance of distance galaxies
as a reminder the velocity
is of a wave so the velocity in which
the wave is propagating is equal to the
frequency times the wavelength so when
we
move relative
to the source of the wave we see this
apparent change in frequency
but let's introduce this topic not in my
words but in the ones of sheldon cooper
from the big bang theory
we go to the party i don't care if
anybody gets it i'm going as the doppler
effect
no it's not if i have to i can
[Music]
so what time does the costume parade
start
the parade yeah so the judges can give
out the prizes for best costume the most
frightening most authentic most accurate
visualization of a scientific principle
oh sheldon i'm sorry but there aren't
gonna be any parades or judges or
prizes
this party is just going to suck
oh come on it's going to be fun and you
all look great i mean look at you thor
and oh peter pan that's so cute
actually penny he's right peter pan
i got a handful of pixie dust with your
name on it
[Laughter]
no you don't
i hate what sheldon's supposed to be oh
he's the doppler effect yes it's the
apparent change in the frequency of a
wave caused by relative motion between
the source of the wave and the observer
oh sure i see it now the doppler effect
all right
the doppler effect so now we have it
all right so let's look at a specific
situation here
in which we have a sound wave emitted by
a moving car the car is moving with a
velocity u
and is emitting sound with the engine or
the horn of the car if you then look at
the wavelength as we observe so we have
an observer here
as we observe the
wavelength the wavelength is actually
modified because the crests of the
moving car the horn
the engine they are moving themselves
with the velocity u times t zero which
is the period which is equal to u times
one over the frequency as the frequency
emitted by the car at rest
so the wavelength is modified to lambda
minus u times 1 over f0
so then we can use this equation here
to calculate the wavelength at the
frequency as observed by this person
here which is the velocity of the moving
wave divided by the modified
or the the observed wavelength and so
that's v over lambda minus u
times 1 over f 0 or
f 0 times 1
over 1 minus uv
all right so we see that the frequency
is modified when we observe the moving
car
and you have all experiences in life
already so let's look at a few more
examples of this
let me just share this little video it's
a very short video
so you were able to hear the change in
frequency in this example
there's another one
[Music]
so this is interesting now
so you've heard exactly what i was
describing before the sound of a moving
vehicle
in the first case a car honking in the
second case a european fire truck
passing by
and so there's an additional part to
this story here if i would ask you
please to make the sound of a fire truck
i think not many of you would say nina
nina nina which is the sound of this
fire truck for european
there's a few more of those examples
which are really weird if i ask you to
make the sound of a rooster
you and i will probably disagree on the
sound of a rooster i would say kikiriki
and you would make a sound which is
rather unfamiliar to me so that's just a
fun fact on the side but
this was a short introduction to the
classical doppler effect and in the next
video we will look at the relativistic
doppler effect
you